hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
quick reaction auf meinem kanal denn
wenn wir uns heute richtig entscheiden
gewinnen wir zehn millionen euro veganer
es damit
könnte ich nicht krass reisen weil wir
sind gerade in quarantäne
hey leute und herzlich willkommen bei
wissenswert stell dir vor du lernst
einen sehr alten und sehr reichen mann
kennen ja will ja hallo sagen
er selber keine kinder hat und überlegt
hier sein vermögen zu vererben yanar
bruder habe zehn millionen euro hat er
auf dem konto
einfach so wirst du das geld nicht
erhalten vor eins plus 12
um sicherzugehen dass du die zehn
millionen erhältst stellt er sich vor
sieben entscheidungen
7 ich dachte eine aber sieben
kritisieren und zu testen was dort
wirklich ein herzensguter mensch bist ja
okay es geht darum dass wir herzensgut
sind als ich dachte eigentlich dass es
geht jetzt darum bekriegen trasse
mathematische rätsel wir müssen schlau
sein wie sonst nie wir müssen mit dem
herz nachdenken heute ich hatte
verpacken nur wenn du immer die beste
entscheidung für deine mitmenschen
triffst wirst du am ende belohnt
ich sehe schwarz
wirklich sozialer mensch bist das werden
wir am ende des videos auflösen okay
beginnen wir mit der ersten entscheidung
du bist mit deinem drei hundewelpen am
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe 300 ich brauche die zehn
millionen und gerade bis zum kopf im
sand eingebuddelt hier ist eine große
haarige spinne in wenigen augenblicken
zu den hundewelpen laufen wird sie
beißen könnte
da hilft ist nur für die hunde
gefährlich will kann die spinne nichts
anhaben ja sie befindet sich direkt vor
deinem kopf hier könnte sie beißen und
sie somit außer gefecht setzen daher
würdest du das tun um deine drei
hundewelpen zu retten
ist die spinne
durchgeschnitten entscheidest du dich
für die rettung der hunde durch den biss
der spinne a oder b verzichtet du okay
und von ekel
also klar wenn ich aber sage ist es
wahrscheinlich richtig und wir bekommen
das geld allerdings seit der verdammten
auf der einen seite hatte ich halt
spinnen wie die pest aber auf der
anderen seite liebe ich hunde und vor
allem welten und vor allem golden
retriever welpen und das sind gold wie
war welt war daher ja klar wie die
spinne töten
die schmeckt wohl seine haarige spinne
ein paar sekunden später kommen wir zur
nächsten
a
okay wir kriegen die antworten erst am
ende des videos also ihr müsst dran
bleiben leider ein zug fährt auf eine
gruppe von fünf menschen zu und lies
festgekettet wurden
es sind kinder als auch ältere
erwachsene unter den menschen ok auf dem
einzigen anderen gleis ist ein einzelnes
kind nicht fest gekettet wurde
aber weil es stolperte nicht mehr vom
gleis hochkommt du stehst neben dem
hebel der die fahrtrichtung ändern kann
es gibt jetzt zwei optionen optional
wäre nichts zu tun und den menschen die
von einem kriminellen am gleis
festgekettet wurden ihrem schicksal zu
überlassen
dafür das kind auf dem anderen gleis zu
retten oder du entscheidest dich für
option b in diesem fall legst du den
hebel des kreises und der zug überrollt
das kind du hättest dafür aber die fünf
menschen gerettet welche entscheidung
triffst du
ich will mein bizeps wird den zugang zum
all das ist ja extrem schwierig also ich
meine vorhin konnte und sich noch denken
was gegen wie wichtig wäre für den
verlauf des videos
allerdings ist es hier ja echt also soll
der zug ab bieten und das kind töten was
selbst darauf gefallen ist oder weiter
geradeaus fahren und die fünf das ist ja
da setzt man hetzt man ja menschenleben
aufeinander es ganz schwierig ich würde
sagen option also dass der zug über das
kind fährt aber das ist ja das ist ja
das geht ja richtig in den kopf rein
schreibt immer gerne eure antwort und in
die kommentare aber wir machen jetzt
weiter mit der nächsten entscheidung du
wirst von dem reichen alten mann vor die
wahl gestellt würdest du dein leben lang
auf das internet verzichten oder für den
rest seines lebens keine freunde haben
wenn du dich für entscheidest hättest du
nie wieder internet dafür aber freunde
mit b entscheidest du dich für das
internet aber gegen jede
freundschaftliche beziehung die in
deinem leben noch entstehen kann
wer entscheidet sich denn da bitte auf b
wer also jetzt mal real talk ich meine
für mich ist das in einer gewissen form
noch eine andere situation so ich
verdiene mein geld mit dem internet aber
ich würde mich ja trotzdem nicht für das
internet entscheiden sondern für freunde
so klar man kann jetzt argumentieren
übers internet findet man dann
vielleicht auch irgendwie neue freunde
aber das ist ja ausgeschlossen also
hundertprozentig auch hier wieder a
ich habe bisher jedes mal angenommen die
nächste entscheidung du stehst in einem
hochhaus auf dem balkon einer wohnung
die alte katze der nachbarin über dir
ich auch schon mehrfach angegriffen hat
das nicht mehr so fit wie früher ja
rutscht vom geländer des balkons du
hältst gerade dein neues handy mit
beiden händen fest und sie ist plötzlich
die katze fallen sehen nur retten wenn
du dein handy auch fallenlassen würdest
würdest steht die katze
obwohl sie sich schon mehrmals
angegriffen hat und bereits in einem
hohen anteil ist es ja wieder so klar
ihre dfb sein neues handy wichtiger wer
so klar die katze fällt vom balkan aber
man kann sie nur retten wenn man dann
sein handy fallen welt also ich mit
meinem handy ist es so ich habe dieses
apple care plus also wenn damit was
passieren sollte dann bekomme ich quasi
neues handy kostenlos und allgemein es
ist ein leben gegen ein gegenstand ich
meine klar natürlich wenn es heute nicht
dieses apple care plus haben und
vielleicht auch jetzt nicht überhaupt
sich jetzt gerade mal nach monaten oder
jahren handy leisten konnten dann sind
die wahrscheinlich eher zimperlich vor
allem fällt die ganze einheit jeden tag
einfach angegriffen hat und die die
schon total alte aber trotzdem würde ich
selbst das leben der katze retten also
jeder der sich dafür entscheidet alter
der kann gerne ein kanal abonnieren
die abonnieren ich habe soll wieder mit
meiner sprache der alte reiche man will
nun der letzte entscheidung haben
diese ist für ihn die wichtigste okay
also wähle deine entscheidung ganz
bedacht ja wenn du die wahl hättest das
würdest du lieber angelogen werden oder
b selber lügen
[Musik]
ich glaube der alte mann will hören dass
wir angelogen werden
somit hätten wir uns auch einfach immer
für entschieden und ich glaube das ist
auch der richtige weg um die zehn
millionen euro zukommen wenn ich das
ganze jetzt allerdings ehrlich
beantworten müsste dem safe selber lügen
also ich meine lügen sind jetzt auch
nicht immer so krasse sachen sondern
auch wenn man sagt ja ich bin fünf
minuten da und man schafft es nicht das
ist es ja quasi auch gelogen für den
video verlauf würde ich mich für
entscheiden wenn ich allerdings komplett
ehrlich antworten müsste würde ich
besagte denke aber dass du das geld nur
erhält wenn du alles so entscheidest wie
es der alte mann von einem guten
menschen erwartet
ich hab so ein bisschen die theorie dass
der alte mann sagt jo du bist ein guter
mensch wenn du ehrlich bist und da dubai
allem das geantwortet hast was ich hören
will bist du nicht ehrlich also kein
guter mensch ergo bekommst du nicht das
geld lösen wir jetzt mal auf wie du dich
hättest entscheiden sollen um das geld
des alten mannes zu erhalten bei der
ersten entscheidung mit den hundewelpen
und der spinne sollte der alte mann dass
du dich für sie einsetzt er will dass
sein erbe jemand erhält der mutig ist
und sich für andere stark machen
die zweite entscheidung mit dem besuch
und der frage ob du eingreift und das
gleich wechselst ist eine sehr
schwierige jahre alte mann wollte dass
du dich dafür entscheidend einzugreifen
und somit einerseits die menschen
rettest ach so in der gruppe der fünf
leute waren ebenfalls kinder
du bist zwar kein held aber der alte
mann findet du hast das richtige getan
irre bei der entscheidung zwischen den
freunden und im internet erwartet der
mann von dir eine klare entscheidung und
zwar für lea der alte mann ist einsam
und hat selber keine freunde und
förderer erwähne ich dass es dir später
genau so geht er bei der frage mit dem
balkon bilder an dass du dich für
entscheide slogan fetteste habt ihr
eigentlich immer noch alles so
entschieden wie es der mann verlangte
bisher war es auch immer ein bisschen
einfallslos bei der letzten entscheidung
zu der frage ob du lieber angelogen
werden willst als selber zu lügen ging
aus dem alten land vor allem um eine
sache und zwar um ehrlichkeit herrlicher
mensch sollte ja eigentlich nie lügen
doch wenn ihr euch entschieden habt für
das hier lieber angelogen werden als
selber zu lügen nur um den alten mann
zufrieden zu stellen und das geld zu
erhalten dann habt ihr wahrscheinlich
selber gelogen wie sieht es denn bei
euch aus hier alles so entschieden wie
es der mann verlangte hättet ihr
theoretisch das geld erhalten
[Applaus]
theoretisch theoretisch wenn du dich
richtig entscheidest gewinnst du zehn
millionen euro an der stelle habe ich
das heute wieder jetzt allerdings auch
beende meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann das gerne mal einen
daumen hoch unter dem video her da ich
hab euch das komplette video von
wissenswert auch unten in der video
beschreibung verlinkt also schaut dort
gern mal vorbei auf meinem 2 kanal habe
ich soeben auch ein neues video
hochgeladen
da ging es um den koffern dance und
dieses krasse halbleib bereits gesagt
gern mal und in die kommentare ob ihr
alles richtig beantwortet hat oder wie
ihr euch bei einigen anderen sachen
eventuell entschieden hätte allerdings
befinden uns jetzt auch im auto die oben
ist diesmal die eingeblendete darauf
legt macht das einfach mal da passiert
was wundervolles ihr könnt nämlich
abonnent von meinem kanal werden
ja
auch nicht so toll sein vielleicht auch
lieber lassen und hier ist das video von
meinem zweikanal was gerade online
gegangen ist